[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir
leckeres lammfleisch beziehungsweise
eine marinade für lammfleisch auf die
türkische art auf türkisch heißt spd so
nah und ich zeige euch zwei varianten
entweder könnt ihr das bei schönem
wetter grillen oder ihr nehmt die
gleiche marinade und pack das in den
backofen das hatte ich letztens gemacht
als meine eltern zu besuch war und die
haben so geliebt und ich habe gehofft
film ich das eigentlich nicht ab ich
mache jetzt ganz knackig und kurz ihr
findet die ganz genauen mengenangaben
wie immer hier unten in der video
beschreibung in der infobox
vor ihr haben sie also unter dem titel
einfach aufklappen und dann könnt ihr
die ganzen zutaten gehen ansonsten
hinterlassen einen kanal ein abo wenn es
nicht schon längst getan habt dann
verpasst ihr solch genialen rezepte von
mir auch nicht mehr ich habe direkt habe
ich mal sagen ich nehme mir jetzt auf
meine zwiebeln die wir jetzt hier direkt
in eine große schüssel wobei ich alles
rein kommt fein gerieben ich nehme mir
wirklich diese feinste feinste seite
dann reibe ich fröhlich vor sich hin
sieben habe ich das komplette
eingerieben jetzt gebe ich noch
knoblauch mit der zug noch presse der
einfachheit halber es geht am
schnellsten und gibt dann auch schon
alle anderen zutaten mit dazu
ein bisschen paprika marken nicht zu
viel wirklich nur so nicht mal so einen
vollen teelöffel und halben er die basis
ist übrigens olivenöl und ich hab euch
da auch die ganz genaue gramm angabe in
die infobox für blutige anfänger
gospelchors oliven würdest du hast ja
dass unser und live nös verlegen ich
euch natürlich in die hinterm berg dass
es kalt gepresst und nativ extra
schmeckt sehr gut natürlich salz und
pfeffer und an weiteren gewürzen nämlich
gar nicht so viel rein möchte ja auch
noch den geschmack von lammfleisch haben
und den nicht so übertünchen ich habe
jetzt hier tun ja nicht findet er passt
sehr sehr gut angeblich direkt damit
rein und bisschen chili ich persönlich
gibt nicht so viele die rein ihr könnt
auch falls ist da hat mein china böller
gehört nehmen wenn in diesen extra kick
haben möchtet falls sie denn da habt
gebt den stattdessen reine gute
messerspitze es geht nochmal so den
anderen krieg sag ich mal eigentlich
muss es gar jetzt noch verrührt werden
und dann gehen wir schon die
lammkoteletts mit rein
[Musik]
so das war's auch schon das ganze jetzt
schön ziehen lassen damit es auch
richtig gut schmeckt und das fleisch die
gewürze richtig gut aufnehmen kann das
dauert jetzt so ungefähr vier stunden
wenn ihr die zeit habt am besten über
nacht ihr könnt also auch im vortrag
vorbereiten zugedeckt in den kühlschrank
stellen und dann könntest entweder am
nächsten tag grillen auf dem grill
dauern die von beiden seiten wirklich 45
minuten je nachdem wie durch die
koteletts haben möchtet aber ich hab ich
ja gesagt ich zeige euch auch die
backofen variante und das mache ich
gleich nach dem jährlichen schön
durchgezogen sind nach der kühl zeit
nehmen wir uns dann für die backofen
variante einfach ein backblech ich habe
da schon ein backpapier untendrunter
gelegt und gibt da jetzt was ich mache
jetzt nicht alles weil die andere hälfte
wollte ich hätte gerne grillen und da
gebe ich jetzt die hälfte einfach drauf
ihr könnt auch gemüse dazugeben das
video sich super an vor allem kartoffeln
weil die müssen gar nicht vorhergesagt
werden die waren dann im ofen mit ihr
könnt auch paprika dazu nehmen alles was
sie so da habt
ich habe jetzt hier bio kartoffeln
ich bin nämlich jetzt auch mit schale
das sind übrigens fest kochende könntet
auch vorwiegend festkochende nehmen und
nicht einfach mit dem welt schneider
oder mit einem normalen messer
durchschneiden
dann noch mit dazu geben
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich noch ein bisschen und
neben öl oben drüber und jetzt ist ganz
wichtig dass wir noch ein backpapier
oben zu überlegen und das ganze mit
alufolie versiegeln weil sonst wird
trocken nämlich schon jetzt noch zwei
streifen
und jetzt kommt das in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze erst mal 40 minuten nach dem
40 minuten nehmt ihr die alufolie ab und
lasst sie noch einmal für 15 minuten bei
gleicher temperatur freunden in der
zwischenzeit man auch die kartoffeln gar
und ihr könnt euch das ganze mit einem
leckeren salat schmecken lassen die
grill variante geht ja wie gesagt super
einfach und ansonsten möchte ich das
video auch kurz und knackig halten und
das an der stelle sogar beenden weil ihr
hier einfach immer wieder darauf
zurückgreifen könnt wenn ihr mal eine
schnelle leckere marinade für
lammfleisch benötigt ich wünsche euch
jetzt viel spaß und ausprobiert
hinterlasst mir auf jeden fall feedback
unten in den kommentaren und dann würde
ich mich freuen wenn ihr beim nächsten
video auch wieder dabei sein
kiki
[Musik]